all his friends all his family everyone
that knows him knows it's not gonna work
she was so mean I feel so bad I feel bad
for Peter I feel going from Madison it's
amazing I thought last night she was
gonna go in there and be like okay I
support my son I love my son and that's
not what happened she said on TV that
Madison and Peter will not make it which
maybe they won't but the part that
really got to me was when she said
Hannah and compromised and Madison
wouldn't compromise I have to tell you
completely two different people that one
was willing to compromise the other one
has not now it's like yeah she wanted
compromise her values she gave your son
a choice it was a lot to take in I agree
I thought barb was gonna come in a
little more middle ground but she really
drew a line well what I thought was
really interesting was that she got so
much fan hate on Monday that I thought
that she would use the live show to
recover but she really just could not
help herself I am that barb last night
and I think she's great I think she was
very sweet - I think barb took it
overboard a little bit and all different
ways she's gonna have to fail to succeed
that's it but I understood a lot of
point she was trying to make do I feel
horrible for Mattie yes because that is
a very shitty situation we put in how do
you respond to that that's someone's
mother you know if you're if you can't
get along with the family a lot of
people say you marry into the family so
it's just starting off rocky I agree
with all sides I think there's always
multiple sides to every story
I can see barb side as a mom like she
loves her son so much and she's so
protective and I as much hate if she's
getting I kind of commend her just
because for a mom in the public eye to
stand up for what she believes in and
her son is scary and she knew the
backlash she got and she did not back
down what
however and I think whether you agree
with that or not it's respectable one
only gave his heart to him and that was
Hanna Anne I have a soft place in my
heart for barb but it was hard when she
kind of gave an ultimatum of her own
with this relationships not going to
work and I'm not going to accept it and
that was kind of hard to watch like
being in a really close family myself I
know how difficult that can be in a
relationship do you think barb
overstepped you know it's hard to say
because like I'm not a mother
so like about the mother I don't know
how I would feel if my kid like what's
going through them I saw in my pride and
joy like you know what I mean so I don't
know I mean honestly she just cracked me
up and I was here for all things barb
[Music]